من بعد ما صار الزلزال والناس تعاطفت مع
كل المنكوبين بسبب حجم الكارثه الكبير
بدات المساعدات وجمع التبرعات من جمعيات
ومنظمات وشفنا حتى مبادرات فرديه ودوليه
للمساعده لكن في اشخاص من ضعاف النفوس
قرروا انهم يستغلوا الزلزال وبداوا
يحتالوا لجمع تبرعات بيقولوا انهم راح
يساعدوا فيها سوريا وتركيا ولكنها بتكون
ايش وهميه وبس بيسرقوا فيها الناس وعبر
وسائل متعدده كلها رقميا الاول عن طريق
حسابات على تيك توك بتنشر فيديوهات الصور
وبتطلع بث مباشر لساعات بتحط فيه البث هذا
صور الدمار والضحايا وحتى بيجيبوا صور
مؤثره مو من الزلزال اصلا يعني وبيرفقوا
معها عبارات يستعطفوا فيها الناس مثل من
اجل سوريا ومن اجل تركيا وغيرها الكثير
واللي بيسال طيب كيف بيتبرعوا عبر تيك توك
تيك توك تحديدا في ميزه اسمها هدايا رقميه
وهي هي هذه الناس بتهديها بعض خلال البث
المباشر وبتتحول هذه الهدايا الرقميه
الفلوس فبيطلعوا المحتالين في لايفات
وبيطلبوا هدايا من الناس على انه راح
يحولوها لفلوس ويتبرعوا فيها وكان طلع
كمان متحدث باسم تيك توك وقال انهم
بيعملوا على
منعتيال وتضليل ابناء المجتمع الراغبين في
المساعده الحقيقيه يعني اما الطريقه
الثانيه فهي عبر حسابات على تويتر بتنشر
تغريدات صور مؤثره مع روابط للتبرع عبر
حسابات او محافظ باي بال رقميا والمختصين
اللي بيحذروا من هذا الاحتيال بياكدوا
للناس انه بايبل اصلا من 2016 مو شغال في
تركيا اصلا فما تنخدعوا باي احد يدعي انه
حسابات هذه في تركيا والضحايا الزلزال في
ناس كمان مكتفه وبتغريدات بس بل انشئوا
حسابات كامله مزيفه للاغاثه على تويتر مثل
اللي شايفينه امامكم عشان تبين او تظهر
كانها منظمات شرعيه او منافذ اخباريه
وبيجمعوا التبرعات فيها وبيحولوا الفلوس
لحسابات باي بالخاصه فيهم وعلى فكره تويتر
اغلق احد الحسابات هذه وشغال كمان على
اغلاق حسابات اخرى اصلا
[موسيقى]